[Music]
and wide mugshot news why do you like
this probably that's me my big ass face
if I ever get arrested submitted by
empanadas I love it but not this much oh
my god what kind of sweet kind or the
cold
how much is James baby well I'll start
with the savory and I end it with the
sweets or even that is Mexican I don't
know
the Portuguese or Brazilian I know
Brazilian fell down what's the round one
a pendejo oh they're home love proposal
I love a saucer is that Salvadorian
cause it's like a tortilla but it
doesn't open that [ __ ] [ __ ] burns
those [ __ ] are supposed to be
[ __ ] hot when you eat it then pickles
you ask any [ __ ] Salvadoran you eat
that [ __ ] when it's burning I'm
surprised because I've just never had it
when it was burning you're supposed to
because the cheese inside is [ __ ] hot
hot yeah and you don't eat it with your
hands if you don't eat what your hands
even if it's hot they [ __ ] [ __ ] on
you about that [ __ ] you can't stand I
like it I like it but it's so messy oh I
just want to see how much you two
together so Fez is cool it's too much my
sandwich yeah sure I say I can't have
all that's why what they do is they put
a little toast batter on the top of a
soppy and then you can do a lot of that
was it makes more messy man yeah they do
that up
tacos out guard all just use a fork and
a knife
yeah guard all in 200 internet sensation
Charles wide neck McDowell oh my neck
thoughtful does have a white ass yeah is
now back in jail what was he in before
for no and I won no like it was getting
off APIs right he's human in the long
neck
on the new mug shot he's like damn what
kind of color shirt is gonna fit around
that [ __ ] this man will never get choked
wait have you seen the internet
conversation or people having oh my god
Titanic yeah they just keep going like
every single one you guys have to pull
it up that [ __ ] had been dying and it's
hard to have me dying
amen don't be mean to him he's been
neglected hi dad Nick yeah does he lift
weights cuz his neck is widest finger
that's just like a genetic dysmorphic
well the way he's lifting weights is
probably like he gets a [ __ ] bet like
a like a barbell and then he ties it to
his [ __ ] head and he's like doing
this all day he looks like he's half
like shark dr. Dre the chronic oh no
next licks fish they just put in space
and hopefully connect for yeah there's a
there was like a conversation of people
there's this one photo of the sky no but
he's a celebrity in jail there's a photo
who this guy he was pointing a gun out
his window yes listen but it was like an
old musket gun and then one of the top
comments was that gun cost 10 shillings
in a bag of wheat that [ __ ] was one of
the best threads I've ever read [ __ ]
Barney I found the thread that geo
talked about you people should be
ashamed of yourselves all this
negativity isn't right
the neck is still at large what neck of
the woods was he caught in they're gonna
put him in jail and throw away the key
he'll be at a jail neck week anyone
notify his next dude up to his neck in
charges who looks like they're gonna
charge this guy with necklace and
dangerous my neck my back they took my
meth and my crack oh god I love the
internet so much damn Larry
how does someone that like is off
against everything bigger so you can
swallow bigger amounts of food or is it
just or does he have a small head you do
a 10-year challenge broad neck he did a
tender jump who's always headed duffle
can't even fit in a picture oh can you
turn his back I want to see his family I
want to see what his family looks like I
want to know if he's had it since birth
and it was for sure it's a birth thing
did I pull away children on man what was
he in for before what's he in for now he
never choked him dude he's arrested in
Alabama for allegedly eluding law
enforcement reckless driving driving
with a revoked license improperly music
and a second degree possession of
marijuana charge Oh like when you're
already committing one crime don't do
two things at once like if you don't
have a license don't drive with wheat
yeah what the hell are you doing during
his first arrest he was booked for
eluding possession of cocaine meth and
marijuana
what's eluding possession he could have
done something like this no eluding
comma possession of cocaine
what's eluding running awaiting a boom
yeah he could have done something with
this the social media yeah I think he
did that to get back in the limelight
maybe dude I don't know if he's making
money you got a guy like bran yells for
turtlenecks scarves well he met braces
first one neck braces
scurs
his first mug shot that went back looks
like he has no chin yeah it melted into
his neck yeah but that means Adam's
apple doesn't show at all oh good how do
people like this exist he looks like a
friendly guy but then the long neck guy
the long neck and head along that it's
like a interesting duo yeah he looks
crazy he looks like a human [ __ ]
daddy longlegs some people only get like
worth in their neck you can get a whole
Bible and [ __ ] I know I won't get a
whole [ __ ] Chucky is verified on
Instagram though one pissed oh man come
on man oh man how does he get verified
and we don't you know what I read to
that on Instagram that they'll verify
people that they they their names will
come out in an actual article like by a
media like news media if someone
actually mentions you then that's how
you'll get verified somebody write about
us please somebody make a [ __ ]
Wikipedia please somebody make a
Wikipedia about a JK nurse please viral
so many times we've been around for like
a long time please I don't want to be
too I don't want it to be too famous
you know why we'll have to change oh he
was born in 87 August of 87 I don't want
to I don't want to change like I want to
stay the good ol 2016 [ __ ] JK news I
know we had to change a little bit
because people are now more sensitive
[ __ ] you forget sensitive as [ __ ] but
imagine the world is gonna get crazy
your can you imagine we're already I
already feel like there's a [ __ ]
Undertaker or like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know like some kind of [ __ ]
those guys that put up those hangars you
know there's [ __ ] chop off the next
looks out the execution execute the
guillotine guys [ __ ] sir Ilyn Payne
you piece of [ __ ] I feel like that
[ __ ]
he's standing down I feel like I'm
missing listen and if I and he's a nice
[ __ ] holding on my dick and I sue me
and as soon as I get hard he's gonna rip
it off yo what are you talking about
very confused I
my grandpa Joe's talking about penises
again what is he talking with it what I
feel like is there's somebody's butt
there's a there's a there's a beautiful
woman standing there
wait wait wait before even I don't even
know you were talking about getting
verified and then you went to this how
does that cause you're going crazy there
you go I for you is that have to do with
getting verified no I feel restricted is
what I'm saying why it's because I don't
want to be too famous because we're
talking about birth verification and
getting [ __ ] articles written about
us and Wikipedia I don't want to be too
famous is what I'm saying is then
because we'll have to [ __ ] change
because everybody that is way too big
they're always under a microscope sure
that's what I'm saying I like where
we're at we get to be who we are but
then still that's what I'm saying is I
still feel a little bit restrained but
then you went from there it's like I
don't know where okay so I'm saying that
I'm just saying that the feeling is like
imagine a [ __ ] finisher the
executioner standing there about to rip
off my dick if I get hard okay don't get
hard then why would you get hard cuz
he's touching it just saw yourself he
didn't wash his hands and you won't get
hard or that's why I switch and I say
okay maybe because it's gonna be hot
again like it's gonna be difficult I
[ __ ] myself basically cuz I was like I
pictured his calloused hands with blood
I can't get my dick hard right
so I said imagine a hot girl now wearing
lingerie and she has a flyswatter and
every time I dick gets hard she smacks
that [ __ ] and then it shrivels up again
and that's that's how I feel like when
I'm talking on Jay King news that's what
I was trying to point oh speaking of
calluses so girls or I guess gay men who
lift and have calluses or hand jobs out
of the question
I had calluses before I liked it stuff I
don't even like hand dropping myself
with the callus right like what if it's
like super calluses like or he
well how much cows are you talking about
because he looks like a lot and this
shit's not bad Phil is that I mean it's
rough
you're like freakishly soft in all
places though I feel like your feet are
like super soft
oh okay okay but what if it's like
peeling calluses like I know why are you
talking you know the the pumice stone
you just shave that off all right so
we're talking about daddy longnecks
right there's a photo of the two of them
together
that [ __ ] looks photoshopped I want to
know who hit who up next up you know I
think they got like a manager he was
always like one extra guy okay and he
probably brainchild everything brand-new
how they make money
I don't know they have a management
right maybe like a straw company or
something I don't know you know giraffes
are going extinct so for sure that kid's
gonna do something with that
yes 1.3 million followers on Instagram
by a wide neck wow dude 1.3 million
what about long neck [ __ ] well maybe in
jail somebody [ __ ] smoked something
up his ass and you can [ __ ] post
tweets you probably swallow it yeah it
was pretty good to go dude oh that's why
his [ __ ] neck is so long because he's
drink he swollen up on this way you
could put like three iPhones going up
and [ __ ] as he went boom that's what
happened in the first place
[Music]